fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald takes us back to 1927 and
finds Newt Scamander caught up right in
the thick of the dark wizards mess so
how do all the moving parts come
together in the latest Harry Potter
prequel let's take a look of what
happened at the tail end of the crimes
of Grindelwald this movie finally
introduces us to lead til a strange
newts old friend from Hogwarts who's now
engaged to his brother Theseus in the
Lestrange family tomb leeta reveals that
she swapped her real brother Corvis out
for a less colicky baby after which the
ship they were on sank and her brother
drowned the boy who lived was credence
and he was given up for adoption after
it was revealed that he didn't belong to
the lestranges she does however have
another living brother Yusuf comas who's
on a mission to kill Corvis when leta
sacrifices herself to allow all her new
friends to escape a Grindle volt Hall of
blue flames the other characters might
have thought she could have been the
last of the lestranges pureblood lineage
of course Harry Potter fans know that's
not the case since Bellatrix Lestrange
is such a big part of the boy wizard's
journey many years later we'll have to
wait to see whether and how this loose
thread ties up in later installments
another subplot of the film concerns
newts commanders reluctance to get
involved in the Auris effort to fight
Grindelwald he's asked by the British
Ministry of Magic to join forces with
them in exchange for the restoration of
his international travel rights but he
refuses the offer citing his disinterest
in choosing sides in whatever battle
they're a part of but once he and Tina
bear witness to what Grindelwald wants
to do and is capable of doing he
realizes that this is a fight in which
no one can remain neutral after the loss
of leta new tells CCS that he is now
ready to choose and fight for the side
of the ministry against his encroaching
threat the history of Albus Dumbledore
and Gellert Grindelwald isn't fully
explored in the crimes of Grindelwald
but there are a few hints that the two
were more than just best friends during
their younger years it's heavily implied
that they were actually lovers who cared
very much for each other until their
interest became so starkly divided
before their splits the two made a
decision that they would never fight
each other and that promise was sealed
by a blood oath has been cemented in a
bauble
by Grindelwald at all times even if that
oath didn't stay Dumbledore's hand he
still seems an easy about going to war
with Grindelwald his affection appears
have survived whatever calls there big
splits at least for a time but once he
retrieves the blood oath pendant and
sees away he can possibly break the pact
Dumbledore's changed to Grindelwald may
soon be broken and he'd be able to fight
his old friend throughout the crimes of
Grindelwald credence and the gimme are
on the hunt for his real mother once he
finds a woman he suspected to be his
mother he's disappointed to discover
that she's actually just a family
servants and she's immediately killed
off by a stray spell from the aura
Grimson credence is later Lord to the
Lestrange family tomb where he again
hits a dead end in his search but after
hearing Grindelwald speech about how
Wizards need to take over the world he's
ready to declare his allegiance to team
Grindelwald Grindelwald reveals that
credence his real name is a Relius
Dumbledore and says a Albus Dumbledore
is out to destroy him the implication is
that he is an as yet unrevealed third
sibling or other relation to the
Hogwarts headmaster which has left many
Harry Potter fans scratching their heads
about how that timeline might have
worked out or if this is just another
bit of trickery by Grindelwald to make
credence resent Albus it's clear from
the start of fantastic beasts the crimes
of Grendel vowed that the title villain
is one clever wizard he manages to
escape the clutches of his captors and
flits away to Paris where he starts
amassing an army of wizards by promising
them untold power and dominion over the
known world
meanwhile all of his talk about the
Wizards right to global superiority is
immediately reminiscence of the Axis
powers in World War so if the reference
wasn't already clear enough though the
film crystallizes the connection by
showing scenes of the exact conflicts
such ideology led to with visions of the
city being destroyed by air raids an
atomic bomb being detonated in Japan and
even a glimpse of Holocaust victims
being marched to the camps scenes which
ironically Grindelwald says his plan
takeover of the world will specifically
prevents regardless of one of those
images were necessary however the film
made his point by declaring this war to
be a battle between the very ideas of
good and evil of all the animals that
are introduced in fantastic beasts the
crimes of Grindelwald perhaps of Phoenix
as the most significant the supplement
Grindelwald claim that credence is a
member of the Dumbledore family he shows
him how a baby bird becomes a fiery
creature saying that the animals are
known to come to any member of the
Dumbledore lineage in their hour of need
his words are reminiscent of something
Albus Dumbledore had said about his own
Phoenix Forks and the Harry Potter
series it's unclear whether this new
bird will bear any relation to the bird
that Dumbledore kept in his office for
all those years but if it does the
creature may end up being one of the few
characters who helps bridge the gap
between the stories of Harry Potter and
fantastic beasts will say
[Music]